let me bring in Eric Horne he is the
writer covering the Thunder for the
athletic and he was there last night in
Oklahoma City Eric thanks for joining us
how would you sum up last night oh
thanks for having me dad I know I guess
I'd start by saying it was just strange
I kind of tweeted this out with the
story that I wrote that I've never been
in an arena as long as I've been there
last night not covered a basketball game
when did you get an inkling something
was up in pregame intros after they
introduced the players and then you know
once they got ready to tip-off it just
took longer than usual and you know the
officials were kind of talking to each
other and then you know the thunders
basically head doctor Donnie's track ran
out and that's when you knew but
actually I think that might go the real
indication not even went Donnie's track
right now to me was when their assistant
general manager Rob Finnegan ran out
because it was like okay this is like a
front office guy on the court before
tipoff like you never see this and I was
just like okay this is definitely
related to coronavirus you don't want to
be speculative on the Internet so you
just kind of sat there and soak it up
for a minute and then once the music
kept running once those guys kept
talking and talking and then the players
look confused you were like alright this
is this is the thing this is this is it
this is real and I applaud you for this
tweet in the name of not spreading
misinformation I won't speculate here
lot of people trying to gather as much
info as possible including the team's
thanks for patience that was a
professional tweet by you because it's
obviously confusing time but you know
when the PA announcer makes that
announcement the fans the fans have no
idea what is transpired I'm guessing
yeah yeah everybody's just sitting there
and like I had a friend of mine text me
later that night and they said that they
saw my face and they were like I could
tell that you were trying to figure out
what the hell's going on and that's
exactly what everybody was doing nobody
knew what was going on the only people
that knew
that work what was going on where you
know the people in within those
discussions we were too far away to hear
or what's going on so you know the
players are confused the fans are
confused even the people who are getting
the information from the officials at
the DIA the scores table are confused
and it's basically just a waiting game
from there you know we've heard and
pregame that Rudy Gobert and Emmanuel
mudiay were out due to illness but again
you don't want to speculate you want to
wait and get all the details and then
once the team doctor runs out and they
kind of confer and you start to start to
do some reporting as as our guy showers
[ __ ] it did for the athletic and Tony
Jones as well who covers in jazz you
find out more and then you can kind of
work from there how long did the players
have to stay at the arena so the Thunder
players weren't there as long for what I
understand is the jazz players the jazz
players were there a while I don't have
an exact time as the one they left but I
know that their bus fired up a little
bit after midnight
so if you think about when players
typically get to the arena you'd imagine
that they were probably at the arena
from like their pregame you know warmups
and and and how they get prepped were
prepared for a game until the end of the
night it was probably about a six or
seven dollar process for them the
Thunder was the thunder players were
longer than that because from some other
reporting done from other outlets you
know they were probably they're a little
shorter and they didn't have to actually
get the testing done that the Jazz had
to get there did you get tested I did
not um I thought about it long and hard
but if they didn't require us to get
tested a lot of the people that are
around the Thunder team weren't required
to get tested either Rudy Gobert was not
in the building last night which doesn't
necessarily mean that the virus hadn't
been spread to his teammates but no jazz
personnel
Media who've been around Gobert you know
in the in the in the previous weeks and
then the players were the ones that took
priority
mudiay get tested I don't know that I
haven't heard anything otherwise about
mudiay
or if he actually has the virus he
wasn't one of the guys that was reported
as had the virus last night
I would imagine that he did get tested
because he is one of the players on the
team what I understand they were trying
to figure out last night where those
guys were going to stay tonight because
they stayed in one hotel 21c that was um
on Tuesday night they were trying to
figure out where those guys going to
stay last night and how they were going
to get home today whether it was on the
Charter plane or a charter bus what are
you gonna do now write about the NBA
it's kind of like one of those things
where people ask me in the offseason Oh
what are you write about when the
thunders not playing I'm like yo there's
free agency and there's the draft and
there's feature stories it's like people
act like the NBA just disappears off the
earth once the games end there's always
something to write about and you know
this this is something that's affecting
people more than just on the court so
I'm sure we'll have plenty of plenty of
things and plenty of angles to write
about from there but you know we've been
collecting stuff over the last few weeks
and in preparation for something like
this so I don't think that we're gonna
be short of content anytime soon no but
it is great to have the games I mean if
you're everybody's right in that sense
the games and what's paramount when it
comes to what we do but I don't think
that we're gonna be starving Eric good
to visit with you thanks for joining us
I thought you handled it like a
professional last night and I should not
be surprised by that but thanks for
joining us you do what you can Dan I
appreciate you having me on there thank
you
that's Eric corn he writes for the
athletic covering the Thunder